[Music]
free diplomas news free submitted by
Cham burn loves JK Thank You Jan bear a
billionaire has pledged to pay off the
entire student debt of the 2019
graduating class at a historic black
scholar heard about the bots he did it
in his light graduation speech rotor cuz
he was like part of that class and he's
like he was he like said yeah and no you
guys I'm gonna pay for all your loans
off and stuff
wait he's a billionaire in the class I
think he yeah you went until he finished
his degree or something or like the
amido man honor gave him an honorary
degree tip can tell you where I've been
since he has the article is this like
more college like Howard so he was a
commencement speaker at Morehouse
College oh yeah yeah yeah yeah what do
you know about it well you know I just
did a medical internship and there's
hella students from all black colleges
there we're are all black colleges like
is it all in the south
cuz I don't know any in California oh
yeah well Sam himself this guy got the
standing oh of all time yeah hell yeah
there's an Asian lady in the back
but he was like oh my type I think those
are the professor's in the back these
are all the students yeah I mean that in
that like audience and just hearing that
like on your student loans to pay off I
would have been like I should have
[ __ ] got more beautiful house
brothers and let's make sure every class
has the same opportunity going forward a
stop that's time so they're saying that
the gift to this all-male historically
black college is estimated to be worth
about ten million dollars
there were 396 graduates in the class so
tuition room and board another costs run
about $40,000 per year dude it means so
much to start off your college I mean
you're just adult life without that dude
you have a degree and no debt that is
crazy power bro because that's how they
keep you enslaved really is your tie to
the [ __ ] dead and then that's why
people don't raise up in class classes
for many generations dude your parents
are in debt then you go to school you
leave with that yeah yeah you're the
parents of kids who grow debt yo it's on
me for many generations because everyone
I mean if you go to college and then you
work but you tell your kids to do the
same thing and that's how you get stuck
in this little rat race cycle yeah sucks
because the higher your degree to or
profession more expensive it is you'll
leave college with now $300,000 in debt
if you have a pharmacy or professional
degree you know medical degree or
whatever it is and then you're paying
that for the rest of your life yeah so
you're not really upper class unless you
figure out a method to to get rid of eat
it up how's this guy doing here what do
you do I'm a vet investment oh I thought
he was a cactus farmer well so he may
his five billion dollar fortune from his
private equity firm that's where the
money is in finance crazies you know
that's just one class ten million
dollars one class and it sold ten
million dollars of loans yeah one class
in one college we're just three hundred
students yeah yeah that's a small class
to four hundred 396 yes don't know
there's a bigger school would have like
ten thousand graduating students for
real dude after this though if I see him
anymore like confirming a restaurant
that guy walks in I'm like oh you start
clapping anyway hey waiter I'll take
I'll take seconds I'll get thirds of
this [ __ ] yeah and he just like gets a
glass of water leaves and you're like
yeah right cancel cancel that fillet
that do this [ __ ] so powerful though
because playing it forward for you for
your group your community or whatever
especially if historically it's really
hard to get off your feet and [ __ ] like
I think the only reason why agent
speed-up so goddamn fast is because this
happens because what happens they don't
ask money for the government it's just
constantly you play it forward it's it's
it's kind of like you're supposed to do
it so for example let's say I get
married and then you know I buy homes or
whatever I can for the whole like for my
father-in-law and everything and and
then the the it's like the parents are
supposed to leave a legacy for the
children like they're supposed to have
wealth to give down even if it's small
right so they're always thinking of an
angle and then they do it in a way
that's like super grassroots II but it's
almost like refugees would come here and
they'll all pitch in for a house and
then they build wealth that way or like
how Chinese villagers made a lot of
money is the whole entire village would
when the government allowed them to buy
land they would all pitch in every
single penny but just for for that
village land or whatever and then when
they want a bat build a factory there
the government will buy back the land
for millions of dollars and that's how
they became like millionaires overnight
and stuff like that you guys are really
good too as a culture of Asian culture
is so good at teaching kids about
business and how
start one and how to like how important
it is to like be on time and to do all
the right [ __ ] like yeah [ __ ] I never
got any of that going up well I think
it's the collectivism like society you
say that they also have it's not so much
like this but like that they give you
the tools to actually be a good business
yeah cuz my parents were horrible with
money me too but I think they gave me
the tools Yash's work together in a
group team-up if you can't do it
yourself all of this stuff is just
really important because I think in
America it's more like everybody's
individual everything is like when
you're 18 leave the house go do this and
find your own way and then build your
own family and everything is so I think
the progress is such slower when you
don't pitch in together yeah so I think
in Asian culture it's like if you're the
parent right even if you're 80 years old
and your kid is 60 if they need help or
you just constantly give that's just the
way it goes so what will happen is like
if I have kids the kids will eventually
take over being like the head of the
household but I'd probably live with
them they'd follow us back in Japan or
whatever and then it'll be their turn to
take care of me
yeah that's pretty common out here - it
is but there'll be several families in
one household we're taking care of each
other pitching into the house building
the wealth together doing business
together all that stuff so it's it's I
guess it's the same but I think it's
more extreme in the Asian world so and I
think the wealth is shared a little bit
more like my mom and probably like all
of her thirty friends that are all
co-workers I know not all of their kids
went to college and all of them are debt
free because the parents have been
saving for it and I also know all of
those kids when they bought their first
house all the parents put down the down
payment so it was just a norm for that
class of people to do that so that
already gives everyone a huge jump start
yeah what cause like here specifically
in the u.s. it's like you retire and now
you're supposed to whatever money you
save from every time it you want
vacation you do whatever but then in
Asian cultures it's more like well now
like I've had my time now I'm giving it
back like there's no such thing as like
I'm gonna go and
and like retire and like just blow all
my cash that's true yeah I think it's
just different the way that it's
structured maybe because back in Asia
too they don't have a lot of the same
opportunities so they have to be extra
clever in how to make money and how to
keep money it's just kind of in their
system when it's confusion confusion is
when that collective isn't - but you
know my dad he's uh
so he has a house I think it's worth
like 500 or 600 now and I think he
realized he'd rather just be closer to
tiger
so he's like hey you know what I could
do is I'll just sell it and I could just
give you pretty much 300 of it and then
I'll just keep 200 and I'll just rent
I'll just rent a little town house close
to you guys so they'll make my drive
like five minutes so it's just it's just
always thinking big picture right he
does even care if that he paid off he
spent 20 30 years paying off his house
and then he has a house that's worth
half a Miss or something more important
I'll just give you the money because in
Tiger could benefit from this money
later on when my cousin got laid off my
uncle down paid a home and then they
only had to take pay pay a portion of
the mortgage and in the agreement was
like you just live here for like 15
years or whatever it is and then when
I'm ready to retire then I'll just move
in and I don't know they figure out ways
to keep it within the family I'm sure
other cultures do this too but I feel
like the reason why a lot of people can
come here broke and then and then come
up with in just one generation is
because of the pitching in aspect of it
and everyone just trying to make each
other rich Ryan - your pants right make
you rich they've definitely set me up in
a lot of good ways for like not having
hella debt like because your hell
Americanized yeah American eyes but my
dad's like was pretty good about like
seeing all the mistakes that like he saw
other people make as far as like having
deadly coming out of college like hella
debt and stuff so then like when looking
for colleges that's why I went to a Cal
State it's cuz like I could we could
afford it you know and they're like
instead of dorming because that would
have been more fun but we couldn't
afford it so I just drove back and forth
for four years oh-ha but because of that
like I don't have any debt like I you
know and do that with the stuff that
they had saved
knowing that me and my brother would be
going in college to like pay that stuff
off so we didn't have any debt were you
pretty much paid off like drooling into
college like you were like um they
already had the money aside I mean I
still got a job like I still contributed
I basically got a job and started paying
paying like a rent or whatever and I had
like a little bit of spending money to
like you know do stuff around but like
yeah we were pretty much set up to pay
for all the tuition and books and stuff
Oh crazy and then we also we also I also
had to pick a college that was like
budgeted you know in a way that like I
wouldn't need him like move to the East
Coast and like you know pay all
crazy-like
out-of-state fees yeah living fees and
just like normal stuff so yeah so that
definitely but that's sort of like
mindset and budgeting really what's the
middle class gets hit the hardest yeah
yeah something that is yeah see that's
not we're before we make a purchase we
actually think about if we can pay for
it yeah yeah versus like you buy it and
then you don't you try to scrounge up
and then you're proud of your because
you can yeah it's like I'll figure it
out later is built into credit that's
worth it I know it's something that they
taught me well as far as like reading
stuff it's like just spend it like you
know if you have a thousand dollars and
you know why like you only spend if you
have like a thousand dollars because
we're gonna get the other like you know
X amount of money I don't that make
sense so then that's pretty much how I
spent a little generally how I spend
money is just like okay I could probably
afford this much per month and then I'll
just pay it off monthly dude when I
bought Nikki's ring yeah they were like
you know it's a couple grand or whatever
do it you can pay it off right now
cuz I could have done that yeah and then
they were like or we can do do it in 12
months and they're like here's how much
you pay every every month and I was like
[ __ ] I want to pay it off right now
right but I know that I can build my
credit better by doing this yeah because
of the system that we're in where the
credit score is so ingrained in that how
well you can get but it's like that you
already had that money to pay it off
right then and there
you had it though right I did it wasn't
like they were like or you know you
could buy this like you know eighty
thousand dollar ring and you oh no no
they knew I was not playing that game I
came in for exactly I am your wad of
cash on the table like what can I get my
Kevin with that whoo tang clan shirt
dude I just knew what I wanted to do
yeah but that is so tempting yeah
totally and it worked on me even though
I had every plan on just paying the cash
totally totally
[Music]